so you um worked on both sides most
excitingly with Chappell what can you
speak to what they were doing to longer
their money you know what's in the
record and what's what's public is that
you could speak yeah I mean the cartel
was so and is so gigantic that you know
they set up a few different ways to try
to launder money and again this is what
kind of came out the trial testimony in
through reports but they just had a lot
of runners that was one of their their
ways to do and I think Marty might have
mentioned it and in season one is you
can have people go to banks all over
America and elsewhere and deposit very
small amounts and they won't get noticed
at all Murph's they call them right
nurse it'll take a very long time some
of them will get caught but if you have
the patience and the organization is big
enough I mean it's right under the
government's nose but that's the easiest
way to go about it but it's just suck it
takes so long because these people can
only deposit you know a couple thousand
bucks at a time they got to go under ten
thousand you have to and even if that's
the thing is even if you go right under
ten thousand that'll raise suspicion
some people think oh I can just keep
going to the bank and deposit ninety
five hundred dollars every week yeah
that is just as bad as putting in ten
thousand dollars so now you just need
hundreds of people doing this constantly
and that's more people that can get
caught more people they can get
compromised more people that could
potentially snitch and you end up
getting [ __ ] over that's one way as
well another way is and I think the
cartel has been alleged to do this a
little bit which is you know taking the
illegal cash in the United States
buying commodities t-shirts yes maybe
some produce some other things and
literally driving to Mexico and selling
them on the street or selling them to
vendors and turning the cash that way as
well now I heard yeah there's something
called like an underground peso exchange
or something like that right where and I
heard this was kind of cool maybe you
can correct me on this but I heard that
there's often a broker and the broker
will connect the cartel right with
somebody in Mexico that need
something and somebody in America that
has something so for example there's
this store in Mexico that wants to buy
sorry they wants to sell sofas but they
have to get the sofas in order to sell
them right so the cartel goes hey we're
gonna buy the sofas from the people in
America right we're gonna buy that with
drug money right you just pay us when we
get the sofas now I'm selling sofas I'm
not selling drugs perfect now the person
that they're buying the sofas from in
America the cartel I guess uses the drug
money purchased the sofas they do and
that doesn't get hit with the IRS or
anything it's that's the same thing like
he talks about early on is you can't
push the envelope you know sofas would
probably be up there towards the more
you know larger purchases that can be
made but it literally might be something
as small as t-shirts little trinkets
that you buy at a hobby store and bring
them down and you see these vendors on
the street sell them it's a small
turnaround but that will not raise any
suspicions you move up two sofas you
know obviously that's a little bit
larger for purchase through cash but it
still would not raise you know huge
eyebrows like if you moved up to a car
or something along those lines